pour ce qui le concerne le cas de
monsieur benalla il a géré omis de dire
que le cnaps a été créé en 2012
préalablement c'était les préfectures
qui délivrer les autorisations monsieur
benalla obtenu une carte en 2011 qui a
été délivrée par la préfecture de l'eure
et qui l'autorisait à exercer une
activité de protection physique des
personnes il a demandé une extension de
sa carte en 2014 le 20 janvier 2014 et
il a demandé une extension sur
l'ensemble des activités de sécurité
privée la surveillance humaine et le
gardiennage le transport de fonds la
sûreté aéroportuaire et opérateurs de
vidéoprotection il a fait une dernière
demande très récemment le 28 juin 2010
7,18
non non pas pour obtenir cette fois ci
une carte professionnelle lui permettant
d'exercer une activité de sécurité
privée mais pour obtenir un agrément de
dirigeants j'ajouterai qu'aujourd'hui
enfin que avant que soit mis fin à mes
fonctions j'ai demandé le retrait de ces
deux titres au regard de l'apparition de
nouvelles mentions sur les fichiers